je m'appelle eric bergeault l'eau âgé de
51 ans et je suis cordonnier depuis 1993
un cortenais haut depuis 28 ans
[Musique]
j'adopte la semelle en fonction de la
semelle de la chaussure
tout simplement à étant donné que les
semelles très découpées dépasse
légèrement donc ce sont les petites
finitions
alors cette machine elle moi ça fait 28
ans que je l'utilisent et je l'avais
acheté d'occasion
donc elle doit bien avoir une bonne
cinquantaine d'années
et oui il faisait du costaud à l'époque
a de façon on n'en trouve plus des comme
ça
cet atelier est figé dans le temps c'est
un peu le but c'est ce que je voulais
faire conserver ses traditions de
l'ancien cordonnerie
artisanale un malheureusement les
plupart du temps les machines
électriques
je n'arrivais pas ça marchait pas donc
moi je préfère tout ce qui est manuel
ça me permet de faire des belles couture
bien droite centre dévié de leur
trajectoire
alors vous avez un jour de problème
typique quand rencontre sur ce genre de
chaussures on a l'impression qu'il a une
bonne semelle qui est bien épaisse tout
ça mais l'inconvénient malheureusement
ce sont des talons creux à l'intérieur
donc arrive à ce stade là
malheureusement elles sont pas
réparables l'a exceptionnellement
monsieur il a tellement insisté il me
disait qu'il était tellement bien dedans
que là je vais devoir les réparer quand
même mais il ya énormément de travail
contrairement à ce qu'ont dit les gens
ils jettent pas comme comme ça hein même
avant de jeter la chaussure sur la
chaussure est abîmée ils viennent me
demander si c'est ça vaut le coup ou pas
donc ils font énormément réparer quand
même contrairement à ce qu'on dit c'est
plus des chaussure jetable en entend
parler ça non
si c'est possible si subtile
peu fatigué et c'est vers des bonnes
chaussures ben écoute et à première vue
oui le dessus et encore en bon état le
cuir n'est pas abîmée du tout
l'intérieur de non plus donc franchement
oui elle vaut largement le coup d'être
semblait
ya pas de secret pour l'entretenir une
paire de chaussures c'est le cirage
nettoyage quotidiennement et une fois
que vous enlevez vos chaussures le soir
mais une perdons beau choix roues des
journaux à l'intérieur de façon à ce que
le cuir regard de la forme ne s'agit pas
de passer un petit coup d'épongé humide
c'est pas comme ça que ça marche
malheureusement depuis 28 ans que je
fais ce métier là il n'y a pas une seule
fois où je me suis dit j'en ai marre je
me lance je m'en suis jamais lassé c'est
avec plaisir que tous les matins joue
mon atelier
la joie d'accueillir ses clients
maintenant c'est même plus des clients
pour moi depuis le temps que je suis là
c'est tous deux quasiment des années
meilleures
pas une seule fois la retraite m'a
traversé l'esprit
c'est je peux
jusqu'à 80 90 ans et je suis encore là
je pense que je brille calerait toujours
en cordonnerie re
c'est trop prenons comme métier
la cordonnerie c'est un métier d'avenir
les gens marchent auront toujours donc
ils useront automatiquement et il y aura
toujours du travail pour les cordonniers